the banner saga will take you on an
immersive journey where your choices
directly affect how your personal story
unfolds in this tutorial we'll be going
over the basics of combat which will
cover your strategies and prepare you
for the battle and your tactics in the
field combat in the banner saga is split
between battle and walls a battle is a
small-scale fight where only your party
of six are affected a war occurs when
your caravan meets a large number of
enemies when this happens you will be
presented with a summary of the pending
situation along with several options of
how to proceed your choices here will
affect how many of your side's survive
the fight and your choices at this stage
will also affect how difficult the
combat is before you take part in any
battle of war you have to choose which
six heroes to take with you you can
choose any hero from your entire roster
and you can mix and match any
combination of class you might have
heroes can become injured if they're not
unconscious in battles so you'll have to
rest them for a number of days before
their full strength again before
choosing a hero make sure you are
familiar with their stats armor strength
willpower exertion and break armor
blocks damage your strength minus their
armor equals damage strength is both
damage and health if it drops to zero
the unit full unconscious willpower
expect to move further hit harder
and perform abilities but does not
replenish during combat once you've
spent all your world car you will not be
able to use a hero special ability
exertion is the amount of willpower you
can use on any given direction brake is
the amount of direct damage you can
naturally due to an enemy's armor lastly
make sure that you have promoted or
applied extra stat points to any
qualifying hero and equip any passive
ability enhancing items that you might
have picked up or bought along the way
it's also useful to become familiar with
each heroes special active ability and
how it works in combination with the
other heroes in the party when used in
unison these can turn the tide of battle
in an instant once you have assembled
your heroes you are ready to jump into
battle the banner saga embraces
turn-based tactical combat which means
each unit takes a turn to make their
move similar to a game of chess the
order in which the units will make their
move is shown in the bottom left side of
your screen in the initiative bar you
can hit tab at the beginning of a battle
to show how the enemy stats compared to
your stats armor strength and willpower
are showing when it's your turn you can
move use mobility attack or rest if you
are in range and you choose to attack
your enemy you can either attack their
strengths or break their armor the week
of their armor they're more susceptible
there will be when this rope is directly
willpower can be used in a battle to
boost actions for example if you are
just out of range to make an attack on
an enemy you can use willpower to move
within range or you can add willpower to
boost an actual attack on ice our mobile
strength
well pad boos are a limited resource
however and are determined by your
exertions fat so use it wisely this
completes your rough guide to combat
more details can be learnt in game
during the early tutorial missions to
help you get started on your journey as
you progress and gain experience in
combat you will not only be challenged
more but you will also discover the
deeper strategic combat that is at the
heart of the banner saga to learn more
about the game visit our forums website
and Facebook page